I'd like to see a cut in the Fed rate
because that should have happened a long
time ago I think they're being very
tardy and not doing it and not having
done it sooner they raised too quickly
and I've been quite vocal on that they
also did quantitative tightening which
was ridiculous and so and despite that
you know if you look I guess you could
call it normalized but if you look our
economy is doing fantastically and if
you take a look at the previous
administration they weren't paying
interest they had no interest rates they
had loosening that type thing and
frankly it's a big difference in our
economy is incredible our jobs you look
at the jobs market but you have to be
proactive and so we really need a Fed
cut rate because if you look at what's
going on with the Europe European Union
as an example they're cutting you take a
look at Germany what they're doing and
what they're paying I mean they're
actually doing something inverse they've
never seen nobody's ever seen it before
we have to at least keep up to an extent
so right now we're paying a very much
higher rate of interest and we didn't
follow the world and generally speaking
that's okay but you can't have that much
of a disparity so we're looking for a
rate cut we could be really greatly
helped if the Fed would do its job and
do a substantial rate cut also they were
doing quantitative tightening very bad
to do they should do easing actual
easing no tightening or a minimum they
should be doing nothing about that but
they have to do a rate cut the other
thing is yeah we're looking at various
tax reductions but I'm looking at that
all the time anyway tax reductions
that's one of the reasons we're in such
a strong economic position we're right
now the number one country anywhere in
the world by far as an economy Europe's
got a lot of problems and Asia's got a
lot of problems you look at China
China's had the worst year they've had
in 27 years and they want to make a deal
with us but I can tell you I'm not ready
to make a deal unless they're going to
make the right kind of a deal I'm not
ready to make a deal so I don't I don't
know but I will say this something will
happen maybe soon and maybe a little bit
later but China very much wants to make
a deal
what kind of tax cuts would you look at
we've heard again potential cut payroll
tax indexing and capital gains what
would you accept well you know we've
been talking about indexing for a long
time and many people like indexing and
it could be done very simple it can be
done directly by me and so we've been
looking at that as you probably have
heard I can do it directly so we're
talking about indexing and we're always
looking at the capital gains tax payroll
tax we're looking at I would love to do
something on capital gains we'll talk it
about that that it's a big deal goes
through Congress payroll tax is
something that we think about and a lot
of people would like to see that and
that very much affects the working the
workers of our country and we have a lot
of workers right now by the way we have
more people working today than we've
ever had before in the history of our
country we have almost one hundred and
sixty million people working today I
think the word recession is a word
that's inappropriate because it's just a
word that the the certain people I'm
going to be kind to certain people and
the media are trying to build up because
they'd love to see a recession we're
very far from a recession in fact if the
Fed would do its job I think would have
a tremendous spurt of growth a
tremendous for the Fed is
psychologically very important less so
actually but very psychologically
important that if the Fed would do its
job which it's really done very poorly
over the last year and a half you would
see a burst of growth like you've never
seen before and that would be lowering
interest rates and maybe putting some if
you look at what China is doing if you
look at what Germany is doing if you
look at what so many countries are doing
putting some money in because we want to
compete with these other countries so I
think that we actually are set for a
tremendous surge of growth if the Fed
would do its job that's a big if frankly
the Fed should be cutting and I would
say they should say at a minimum a
hundred basis points over a period of
time not at one time but over a period
of time well I'm not talking about I'm
not talking about doing anything at this
moment but indexing is something that a
lot of people have liked for a long time
and it's something that would be very
easy to do and a lot of people have been
talking about indexing for many years
and it's something that I am certainly
thinking about I can say that a majority
of the people in the white house at the
level that does this kind of thing they
like indexing so it is something I'm
thinking about payroll taxes I've been
thinking about payroll taxes for a long
time whether or not we do it now or not
is it's not being done because of
recession because we are legitimately if
we had a cut in interest rates by the
Fed if they would do their job properly
and if they would do a meaningful cut
because they raised too fast you would
see growth like you've not seen ever in
this country now if you go from the
election that great November 8th date if
you go from November 9th to present
you're talking about almost a 60%
increase in the stock market you're
talking about unemployment numbers that
are the lowest in history in many
categories and overall almost the lowest
ever in the history of our country I
think it was 1969 and we are set to
surpass that number I mean our country
is doing very well when I spoke to the
president we were just walking in and he
said congratulations on the great
success of your economy in your country
and I appreciated that but our countries
doing very well